Hello and welcome. It's June 15,
2023. We're in active Livestream.
54.2. So welcome to the active inference
institute. We're a participatory online
institute that is communicating,
learning, and practicing applied active
inference. You can find us at the links
here. This is a recorded and an arch
Live Livestream, so please provide
feedback so we can improve our work.
All backgrounds and perspectives are
welcome and we'll follow video etiquette
for Live Streams. Head over to
activeinference.org to learn more about
participating in Live Streams and other
projects. All right, we're in
Live stream 54.2. Continuing with our
third discussion on the work,
mathematical foundations for a
compositional account of the Bayesian
brain, we're back with Dean Ali and
Toby. So if each want to
say hello and anything to begin with
otherwise, Ali has some questions ready
and we have some questions that people
have submitted in the meantime as well.
So shall we just proceed to the
questions as we have the same people as
dot one? Great. Okay,
I'm going to jump into some of the
presubmitted questions. So would
it be correct to call equation 4.2
compositional Bayes theorem, which is or
are Bayes's theorem categorically?
And we have the document ready or
anything that you want to share, but
what does it mean for Bayes theorem to
be categorified? And where is that in
the dissertation? Yeah, okay, so that's
a nice question. I would say that
equation 4.2 is
like a sort of basic is like a sort of
it's like a basic representation of the
product law of probability theory.
And so I wouldn't say it's particularly
inherently compositional. It's just
something that is just like an axiom
that is just like a consequence of the
sort of standard axioms of probability
theory. The thing that makes it a little
bit different from the way that it's
normally written in probability theory
is that I've kind of annotated those P
symbols which represent the probability
of a certain event. I've annotated them
each with a subscript, and that
subscript represents where the
probability is coming from or the
probability according to whom. That's
kind of how you can think of it. And so
normally I find this kind of like P
notation to be a little bit confusing
because people often write P of B
given A, and they also write like P of X
given Y or like P of W comma
a comma z. And so in each of those
cases, the sort of content of the P is
kind of different. Like the A and the B
might be events of a different kind
to X and Y, and yet they're all put into
this P symbol, whereas in this case,
with the annotations, it says, like, as
I say, it says according to what? And so
here the little subscript C represents
what's typically called in
compositional probability theory like a
channel or a kernel. But that
is like a kind of abstract way of just
saying conditional probability
distribution. And so the little C means
it's a conditional probability
distribution from space
X to Y, a space Y. And here
I'm thinking of the B as being an
event of type Y and A as being an event
of type A, sorry, of type x. And so the
PC says it's the probability of the
event B of
type Y given the event A
of type x. And so that means that when
you plug these kind of flows of
information together, you make sure the
types match. It's kind of like working
with a strongly typed programming
language. So that type information is
like the main thing that's different
between this and the standard product
rule of probability and it's from that
product rule of probability theory that
you can just write down Bayes theorem,
which is the equation 4.3.
I would say that the reason
why I slightly hesitate to call equation
4.3 like a sort of abstract or
categorical version of Bayes theorem,
even though it's annotated by these
channels, is because you have
this division. And that division isn't
something that's well defined in all
categories, in all situations that you
might want to consider probability
theory. For instance, you might have
this P of C dot
pi thing and that means the kind of Y
marginal of the joint distribution or
it's otherwise known as the push forward
of the distribution pi through the
channel C. That thing might have what's
known as measure zero, which means the
probability might be zero. And so the
division isn't very well defined and so
that expression doesn't always make
sense. Now the thing that
does always make sense on the other hand
is that just product law equation which
tells you how the two ways you can write
down this joint distribution. So if you
have a joint distribution like on the
space x times y, I've written it there,
then you can decompose it into a prior
on x and a channel from x to y.
So that then if you put the
information from the prior through the
channel you get the marginal on y and
that's that push forward thing. Or you
could write the joint distribution as a
prior on Y and a
conditional distribution from Y to x.
And the thing is, obviously we're
talking about the same joint
distribution in both cases. So those two
decompositions, they're sometimes called
disintegrations, those two
disintegrations need to be equal and
that's what that equation is saying.
So that's kind of because it doesn't
have this division in it and because
Bayes'law follows from it and because
it's something you can write down in all
settings, it's kind of more fundamental.
But I quite like the kind of string
diagrammatic form of it which
is something that is drawn. It's not my
invention. I think I originally saw it
in a paper by Bart Jakobs and I
think his student at the time, Kenta
Cho. So in,
let's see equation 4.5
so that's section 4.1.2
on abstract Bayesian inversion.
So yeah, if you scroll down a little,
it's on like page 130 or
130 in my version, which might be
hopefully around the same place in your
version.
Yeah, a little further.
Oh man, no, maybe not. Let me get up the
version on because I've realized I've
opened the wrong version.
Meanwhile, see it so
so the the thing I'm going for here is
the sort of, as I say, the string
diagrammatic depiction. Yes.
4.1.2, it's page 120. Sorry about that.
Yeah, so it kind of shows you how the
information flows. And so this
makes the two processes
quite explicit. So here on the left,
the prior of the joint distribution is
pi. And then you take the sort
of probability, the information from pi
and you copy it and you keep one of the
copies and that gives you your X
marginal. And then you feed the other
one through the likelihood or the
conditional channel C, and that gives
you the other marginal. And so if you
throw away this X information, you get
the Y marginal. And that's what
marginalization is. And that's why the Y
marginal, if you look on the right hand
side, the prior is C after pi,
that's the Y marginal. So this is like
depicting that Product Law. And then you
say you can call something
a Bayesian inversion of C with respect
to the prior pi if it is
something that can go in the box on the
right hand side where I've written C
dagger pi. And the reason I've used this
dagger symbol is because under certain
technical conditions, this Bayesian
inversion thing gives you what's known
in category theory as a dagger function.
And that's something that swaps the
direction of a morphism. And so here
you've taken the thing that goes from X
to Y and you've swapped it and it goes
from Y to X, but it depends on the
prior. And so I've written this little
subscript and so for me, this picture.
It'S. Kind of equivalent to that Product
Law equation 4.2. But I think although
it's a kind of new kind of language, I
think it's a kind of more intuitive one
because you can sort of see how the
information flows through the system.
Sorry, that was a bit of a long answer,
but I think that's how I think of
it. Great. Okay,
next question. Could be a short one.
I'm mostly wondering about how chapter
six will be rewritten. Will it be major?
And when we promise we didn't write this
question primarily to select the best
policy as to where to direct my regime
of attention? Like, should I wait to dig
deeper into chapter six until the
updated observations arrive? Is
reflecting deeply up until chapter five
where I should focus for now? Or is
chapter six something that won't change
too much? And I can still explore that
next week. So this is a great question.
And I'm sorry that the
rewritten version isn't online yet, but
it is really close, I promise. And I am
kind of aiming for it to be done like
next week or maybe let's not hold myself
hostage to fortune. So let's call it the
next couple of weeks. But it's
quite a change in the sense that it's
kind of annoying because it's simpler
but also kind of more structured.
And so that means that there were a
lot of finicky details that
I didn't anticipate needing
to deal with, that I had to deal with,
even though fundamentally the basic
idea is kind of the same but
also neater and simpler at the same
time.
I can go into some details about
the differences if you'd like, or I can
just leave it at that. What would you
rather? Let's return to this in the
three. Okay, yeah, let's do that.
That's a nice idea. So, yeah, I would
say don't dig too deeply into it,
because basically the thing that I've
managed to do away with and sorry for
all the people who've kind of tried to
bang their heads on it already, is. The
kind of pro functor, like optics. Kind
of like the sort of pro functor stuff
with those weird coen things, the kind
of integral symbols that I was using
to define context for statistical games,
that whole thing. It turns out you don't
actually need the complexity of that
structure. And the notion of context
is really given just by two things.
It's really just the prior, which we've
already talked about, and also the
observation you take from the
environment. And so before I thought you
needed to consider not just the
observation, but also the stuff
that might go on in the environment
around the observation that gives you
correlations. But it turns out actually
you don't need that, at least not for
the free energy principle. And so that
makes things a bit simpler because you
don't need that kind of weird structure.
But there's, as I say, some technical
stuff which is very annoying, which made
it also a little bit slightly
annoying to write down and involved by
categories and sorry about that. But
it's actually the fundamental idea of a
statistical game being like a
Bayesian lens which describes the
inference process, maybe like a
parameterized Bayesian lens that allows
you to learn, but a Bayesian lens that
comes with a loss function that's
still the same idea. And it turns out
that loss functions like the relative
entropy and the free energy, they
actually have a really neat categorical
structure. So the things I was calling
like free energy games before or
Bayesian inference games, those are
actually now a lot even neater still.
So that's really nice.
And the way you get predictive coding is
still as like a functor from these
statistical games to dynamical systems.
So that idea is still the same. It's
just actually it turned out that the
statistical games themselves. There was
actually a lot more nice stuff going on
there than I had realized before.
Awesome. All right.
You cite Erisman and Van Bermesh work
on memory evolution systems. To what
extent have you used their work in the
thesis? Would it be correct to say that
there might exist a functor from that
book to your dissertation or indeed to
any of your citations, is there work
someone could do to explore the
connection between the two? To me, this
is a question of one instance if a
learner or researcher performs active
inference on the interface between a
work and a citation more generally?
Great question. Yeah, I think it's a
really nice so I I read
this work by Erisman of Rambamish on
memory reevoltative systems a
few years ago, and I found it very
abstract and confusing. And I was like,
yeah, this is all really nice, but how
does it actually connect to the brain
and how things like brains work?
But I've kind of softened my stance on
it recently, and I think actually
there's some really cool stuff in that
work, some really great ideas about
hierarchical complex systems and
emergence and even things
like neural coding. It's kind
of, I think, slightly in danger, I
think, of being forgotten because people
see it and think, okay, well, how does
it actually make contact with things I
know about now, things that actually
scientists use? And so I
think it would be great to explore the
connections in a kind of more detailed
way. I don't know precisely what that
would look like. I heard a talk,
actually, by don't
know. There may be some on YouTube, I
don't know. This was in Consciousness
Maths of Consciousness like workshop at
the end of April, and she explained
some of the more recent stuff they'd
been doing, and it sounded like actually
there is a proof, I think, that Hebian
learning does actually give you sort
of what she calls cat neurons.
And so before I've been like, okay,
well, it's a nice story, but does
it actually relate to things like heavy
learning, or is it just like an analogy?
But it sounds like it's actually a bit
more precise than I had thought. And
obviously, because of the connection
between things like heavy and learning
and predictive coding, it sounds
like there should be a way to relate
something like predictive coding to
memory evolutive systems. And that would
be really nice because I sometimes think
about this is kind of a direction that
I'm trying to go in slightly, but try to
think about nested active inference
systems. Like, you might have a little
region of the brain and all the cells
are doing active inference, and the
circuits do predictive coding, and they
make up a brain and the brains make up
society and an organization. And that
story of hierarchical complex systems
is really the story that this
work is trying to tell as well. Just in
a different kind of way. And so I think
it's a really fruitful area, and I
really hope somebody does dig into it,
because I think it's great work, and I
think it's just work that was kind of
maybe ahead of its time, so it kind of
got left by the wayside maybe a little
bit. But I'm really glad to see somebody
ask about it now. Cool. Just one
short remark on this, and then alir
Dean, please. It's almost like when
people draw associations,
like a line of sight. Oh, well,
emergence is like this. It's like
they're surveying and can have quite far
vision. But category theory is like
building the high speed rail where it's,
like, locked in. And then we can say
there really is a relationship of this
exact formal type between Hebian
learning and predictive coding. Let's
just say some type so then that
can be really relied on as a
foundational building block. And it kind
of brings those
literatures and merges those streams or
at least adjoins the streams or
naturally transforms the streams, or
whatever the appropriate terminology
would be, but in a really solid way
that's not just like, well, one person
on a mountaintop saw that these two
things could be connected. It's more
like an engineering project that really
locks it in for everybody. Yeah, I think
so. And I hope people are
incentivized to do that engineering. I
think that'd be great. All right, last
of the presubmitted questions.
So, in the par, pazulo and Friston
2022 active inference textbook,
the first question in the recipe for
designing an active inference model this
is chapter six is which system?
This entails three pieces of data one,
the agent generative model, two, the
interface sensory data and actions, and
three, the external environment, the
generative process. So how do these
relevant big chunks of notions from
the recipe for making an active
inference model in the par at
all textbook map to the sections of what
you've done in your dissertation?
That's a nice question. And it takes me
on to a question of action
and active inference beyond the sort of
approximate inference that I was talking
about in my thesis, predominantly.
Maybe here I could draw some stuff, and
so I don't know how easy that is for
you, but I can share my screen. Yes.
Let's see how this will work.
Yeah. Okay. Share.
All right. Can you see my cursor thingy?
Yeah. Okay, cool.
So I like to draw this picture, and this
is like, the little channel c, which
does prediction, and it goes
from here, and it goes outwards.
And this is the inversion,
the approximate inversion, and it takes
in, like, a prior, which comes from
here, and it takes in an observation.
So we could think of this as, like this
is, like, high level belief
and, like, lower level.
And this is like somehow you
get something which gives you an
observation,
and then this gives you like new
belief, high level.
And this thing is a Bayesian lens. So
that's what the Bayesian lenses are all
about. And the thing that
I was talking about in my thesis is
turning this into like a predictive
coding dynamical system. Because you've
got neurons which do this sort of
prediction part and then neurons which
do this passing back of
error signals to do this updating part.
And they have this kind of like bi
directional form and that's really neat.
And so you can put in another one here,
another one here, or you can just start
with your prior which is like something
that I often write as pi up here. And
then this gives you like a new pi at
this point. And so this is going
always from higher level beliefs to
lower level beliefs. And down here you
might eventually get to the lowest
level, which is like if you're thinking
about visual systems, then this
would be like the V one visual cortex
stuff or like the stuff you get in the
retina and you get prediction about
let's say visual signals.
But then the world, you get this
predicted. But then the world comes back
and it actually gives you actual
this is predicted,
gives you actual signals and then the
brain uses that to update its beliefs up
here. And so really the interface is
somehow like this,
okay? And so this is like lens world
and this is like external world.
So that's where the external environment
comes into the picture. And you could
think of everything in here as like
agent. But this doesn't really tell us
much about action and it doesn't tell us
much about interaction. And so
there's another kind of story for that
which is kind of similar in many
respects, which is the story that
is told at least in category theory by
what's known as categorical systems
theory. And there you get pictures like
this. So this is like your world. And
there you've got some system
inside the world and here you've got
another system inside the world.
And so people then draw like things that
are called wiring diagrams to kind of
represent how these things interact. So
let's call this a for a. Maybe there's
another system over here and this is B.
And maybe that's C for A. Its
environment is like everything that
isn't A, it's B and C.
So maybe it's connected like this, I
don't know, some weird wiring
thing actually, maybe that
should go round to here and then this
goes like to that. I don't know,
something like this. This is just what's
known as a wiring diagram. It just tells
you how the systems are coupled
together. And that would be like
specifying how the information flows
across the Markov blankets of your
systems. And so this
box is like the Markov blanket of A.
And then this wiring is like the data of
the coupling of the blankets.
And so there's a whole theory, a whole
sort of story in category theory about
how to sort of compose if you've got
like, you know, if you you know, it has
to compose dynamical systems of this
kind. And so, you know, what? What we do
is we say, okay, well, we we write down
like the type of if we say if we call if
we write IA to represent the interface
like the data of this is like X and this
is like Y or something like that the
kind of shape of the Markov blanket.
Then what system theory tells us is that
for each interface we get a whole
category of systems that you could put
in that box to animate it to make it
like a living system. And then
this is like a closed box at the moment.
And so maybe it just represents the
whole universe which doesn't have any
external environment. But you might also
have something like a company,
so you call it like company X, and that
has some agent which decides what the
company does, or some agent here which
takes in information from the
environment. And so this wiring is
then something that gives you a
morphism from like A and B and
C to X.
And what this dynamical systems
theory tells you is that let's call that
W for wiring is that you get this
functor from din A and din
B and din C
to din X, which tells you
then how to wire all these dynamical
systems together to give you one that
fits into this outer box. And so this
tells you how to do all this for just
dynamical systems. But of course, we're
kind of interested in active inference
systems. And so here you don't just have
some DX by DT thing to
go in here. You've got the
data of prediction and plans
and goals and maybe then something about
how to actually do the inference,
like the statistical game stuff. But
really the story is the same. And so if
you have these boxes,
again, what we can do is if we
have a box like this x to Y is
we can think of an
agent as having as a part of it a way
of predicting, say, X. We think of let's
call these something else, sorry,
let's call these S. So this is like the
sense data that goes into the system.
And then let's call this A, and then
this is maybe like the actions that it
takes. Let's now call this box, I don't
know B. Oh, no, I don't like B. Let's
call it y.
So now let's think. Okay, well, part of
what an active inference agent is doing
is that they're predicting they've
got some high level belief of
type Y, and then they make a prediction
about not just the sort of sense data,
but also about their actions and then
their body samples from this belief
about how they should act. Or you've got
these little cells, these little
mechanisms which try to correct the
prediction errors to make those actions
into reality. And then maybe that gets
coupled to some other system which
receives those actions as inputs. And
you might have another part here which
goes in the other direction which says,
okay, given my actual sense data and
my actual actions, maybe my body is
still learning how to play tennis or
something, what are my new high level
beliefs? And so you can do this whole
story again of Bayesian lenses.
And this goes like that, and this is now
just why? And then this is like S times
A. And this is s times a So you can tell
this story and you can build like,
hierarchical systems, but now you have a
way of filling in each box and
in principle, a way of coupling them
together to give composite active
inference systems, like companies or
like colonies of cells or things like
that. This isn't a story yet that I've
written down, but I know it works.
And I'm in the process of slowly writing
it down. So the
kind of fundamental structures that are
in the thesis are like part of the
story. The main thing that's missing is
kind of like reorienting it's,
just like reorienting this picture so
that it's not like going from here
from left to right. It's like sort of
poking down into the
box, if you see what I mean. And this
is like the stuff you put in. So this is
like your lens
thing here, and you sort of fill in the
box with your lens.
So I think that tells I
mean, that tells you how the chunks of
the thesis kind of fit into the standard
act of inference story. The main job,
at least as far as I'm concerned now,
is to spell out the details and
then start to talk about things like
what happens if we've got Y
and you've got Z's here? What if they're
trying to form part of an organization,
but they disagree about what to do? How
does an organization resolve
disagreements? What if you've got two
signals from your brain to your muscles
that tell you to do different things?
How do you resolve?
How do you get harmonious active
inference systems in some sense? So I'll
stop sharing my screen now, and then we
could sort of return to the
discussion. But that's, again, my kind
of long winded answer. Awesome.
I can share the pictures I see. Dean you
said you shared something, but I can
share some more things. Dina unmute
and then go for it and then Ali no,
I just shared. Something from about nine
years ago that I was doing in my
programming that everything you just
wrote out was I just wanted to share
one part of it. That confirms that you
could come from completely different
places and arrive at the same
destination. The whole bi
directionality, the whole predictive
parabolic. Yeah. You can bring this into
classrooms and have it make sense. It
doesn't have to be esoteric or too
remote, I guess. Yeah, that's great to
hear. I'm really glad to hear that.
Yeah, it's really awesome.
Thanks. Yeah, as I say, there's lots
left to do, but I think an important
part of that is like spreading the word.
It's really great that process is
beginning, thanks to you guys. So,
yeah, the rehearse play reflect cycle
actually begins when you reverse the
direction of thought reading from Dean's
email. Interesting.
Self organized. Yeah. It's all part of
this whole cat. This is the like,
I love the questions that we've had so
far and I want to hear Ali's questions
and then I want to be able to take it
and have people not be intimidated by it
because you can really find yourself
doing these things on a daily basis.
You just don't necessarily identify them
the way that we are. But that doesn't
mean that we have somehow lost
access to the things that we're
discussing today. So I'll just leave it
at that for now. Yeah,
cool. All right,
in the rest of the time that we have
with you for the two Toby.
Ali.
Okay, thank you.
Your video is frozen. Your video
is frozen. Maybe you can just turn it
off.
Yeah, go for it. Thank you. All right.
In basically three to
ridiculously. Next.
Sorry, the notion of Marko, I noticed in
your thesis.
Sorry, Ali there's just a lot of lag.
Yeah.
What would you say is the chapter six
equivalent? Is there yet a recipe
for designing the kind of categorical,
kind of compositional organization that
you alluded to?
I can answer that quickly. Yeah, go for
a quick answer and then I think now it's
better. Ali yeah, so the quick answer?
Well, it's a quick answer, but it's not
a quick thing to do. But there's a great
book on categorical systems theory
in its kind of great generality,
which doesn't explicitly talk about
active inference like I've been, but it
does talk about this kind of composing
dynamical systems in this hierarchical
way idea. And that's the book that's
currently being drafted by David Jazz
Myers. I can circulate a link
to it.
Myers that
sort of spells out the kind of general
structure and I
believe he and
Mateo Capucci have got a paper upcoming
at the upcoming Act Conference
on Applied Category Theory this year,
talking about using that framework to
do kind of cybernetic like things.
And so what I've been thinking about
lately is trying to fit active inference
and the stuff I've been doing into that
framework, which has been sort of
developing in parallel and kind of
fortunately and maybe slightly
unsurprisingly, they fit very nicely
together. And so the pictures I was
sketching are kind of a fragment of that
other framework. And as I say, I think
they go quite well together. Awesome.
Okay, Ali, go for it.
Okay. Sorry about that. All right, so I
noticed in your thesis that you don't
rely too much on the notion of markup
blankets, but instead you use
this notion of polynomial functions as
its more formal or perhaps more rigorous
replacement. With regard to that
in your paper Polynomial life,
you say in the literature on active
inference sorry.
And the free energy principle, there is
much debate about the concept and role
of markup blankets, which are sometimes
conceived to represent the boundary of
an adaptive system. We believe that the
algebraic polynomials will help to make
such thinking precise where it departs
from the established usage of markup
blankets and Bayesian networks. So would
you care to elaborate a bit on that?
And how do you see polynomial functions
as overcoming some of the limitations of
the notion of markup blankets? Yeah,
okay. So I will preface this by saying
I think some people might disagree with
me, but there
is a notion of Markov blanket that
for me is nicely defined, that exists in
the sort of Bayesian statistics
literature. And it says if you've got a
Bayesian network, you can consider the
nodes in that network and you can ask
what are their Markov blankets? And in
particular, you can just define the
Markov blanket of a particular node to
be its parents.
So those
nodes that it's conditionally sort of
dependent on its children,
sort of those nodes which are
conditionally dependent on it and what
are known as its coparent, so the other
parents of its children.
And that's a very nicely well defined
notion, but it's only nicely and well
defined in this context of Bayesian
networks. And so it's like
generalizing that to kind of situations
where you've got interacting dynamical
systems is something that informally
makes total sense. You want to say,
okay, well, I have this thing in the
world and it behaves so it changes in
time, and it's sort of a coherent unity
in some sense. And so it has a kind of
boundary. And because it has a boundary,
information and energy from
the environment always has to flow
through this boundary in order to
interact with it. And that sort of
boundary notion, it seems, is like what
is in other contexts also called a
Markov blanket. And I think if you set
up your dynamics in a particular way or
your definition of Bayesian network in a
particular way, that the two ideas that
might coincide. But I don't think that's
true in general. And I think what people
mean in the literature when they're
talking about Markov blankets, but in
this dynamical context, I think all they
really mean is like boundary or
interface. So the data
of the system, like capacity
for interaction or something like that,
the stuff that is on the edge of the
system through which interactions with
its environment are mediated,
that sort of general idea is something,
again, that appears nicely in
categorical systems theory, but in a
very general way. And it doesn't require
any of the notions of Bayesian
statistics, and it doesn't require
conditional dependence or parents
or children of a graph because you might
have something more complicated than a
graph. Like you might have edges which
are allowed to connect more than one
node, and that gives you a hypergraph.
And there, of course the notion of
Bayesian of marker blanket in the
standard sense that doesn't make sense
at all, but of course the notion of
interface does. And there are certain
categories of interfaces. And those
wiring diagrams I was drawing before are
an example of a category of interfaces.
Like they don't have any data of the
systems themselves. The category just
tells you how to sort of plug interfaces
together. And so I think it's kind of
neater to think about this connectivity
in the interfaces sort of separately
from the stuff that fills the
interfaces, like the data of the
dynamical systems or of the active
inference, like games that I've been
talking about.
And so a really nice kind of category
that you can use to talk about
interfaces and indeed to talk about lots
of other things, but in particular to
talk about interfaces is this category
of polynomial functions. And it
kind of generalizes these wiring
diagrams that I was drawing earlier.
And it does so in a particularly useful
way, I think, which is that if
you sort of formalize the interface of a
system using this polynomial
language, you can start to talk about
interfaces that themselves might change
depending on the context.
So when you get into the car to
drive somewhere effectively, you've sort
of changed your interface because now
you've got this car around you and it
behaves in a different way than if
you're just on your own or if you're
just normally going
about your life. You might blink right,
or you might close your eyes, and that
means that you're no longer receiving
visual signals from the world. And so
if you just say you're writing down your
active inference model and part of the
model is that it receives visual
signals, then talking
about situations where those visual
signals go away.
You. Can do it right, but it's not very
neat. And so to sort of account for
interfaces that might change like this,
it's nicer to be able to say, okay,
well, my interface actually is allowed
to depend on what I'm doing right now.
So I'm currently on a video call and it
means I can do certain things, but I'm
currently wired into the computer so I
can't so easily go and walk around like
the set of signals I receive or actions
I might take might change. And so I
think it's easy to start by saying,
okay, when we're talking about Markov
blankets in dynamical systems, we just
mean like, there is some set that is
like the action set and some set which
is the sort of sensory set. For me it's
just not enough because of the fact that
the world is dynamical context change
coupling might be dependent on like you
might be in an organization and there's
some executive who's in charge of
defining the team structure. And that
means the team structure is like the
wiring of the agents in that
organization, but how
they behave depends on the decisions
that that executive makes. And so their
markup blankets are conditional on those
decisions. And that's something you can
talk about nicely in this polynomial
language because you're allowed to have
systems which affect the wiring of other
systems. But it's really not something
that's easy to talk about in this
standard framework of interfaces
and boundaries that is dominant in the
active inference literature. And I think
that's because really in the active
inference literature, there isn't a
framework for interfaces and wiring and
that framework is supplied by these
categories of interfaces. And so you can
just choose one and you can hope it does
choose one that's appropriate for your
situation that you're trying to model,
but it helps to actually have one that
allows you to do this wiring and that's
something that using category theory
allows you to do because it's all about
composition.
Awesome. The textbooks
will be rewritten. Dean quick thing,
Toby, does the timing of the choice in
your experience really matter?
The timing in what whenever,
whenever you. Do decide to make a
choice, doesn't the effect of the
timing, the whenness of activating that
choice play a huge part in
what follows in terms of the category?
Yeah. So do you mean like if you're
choosing to use a particular kind of
interface language, say or describe a
thing with a particular interface or
like particular kind of boundary?
Yeah. So I agree. And that's
why I kind of tend to work quite
abstractly. So rather than saying I'm
working with a particular kind of
interface language, I'm just saying I
will assume my interface language allows
me to do these certain things. And so
that's not so useful for actually
implementing a particular model. But if
you're trying to think about systems in
general, it's helpful to work
agnostically in that way. And so
the reason I sort of advocate like this
for polynomial functions is I think that
they sort of fit at a nice sort of
intermediate level of abstraction. It's
not to say, okay, well, there is a
collection of interfaces and some
collection wiring them together because
that doesn't tell you actually how that
works. So it is slightly opinionated.
It's different from certain choices that
people in other bits of applied category
theory make. But it does
generalize this simple case where you
have just a single set of outputs and a
single set of inputs or single set of
actions and a single set of
observations. And so I think because of
that it's a nice sort of intermediate
level and I think it's one I've tried to
work with, because I think it's quite
natural. But yeah, you can sort of
totally work at a very abstract level.
And that's what David Jazz does with
his systems, just he just talks about
interfaces in general.
You might not have actions at all.
It's completely agnostic.
Awesome. Ollie.
OK, thank you so much. So my second
question is about the relation between
your compositional account of active
inference and the recent line of
research done in Bayesian mechanics,
namely the discovery of the duality
between FEP and constraint maximum
entropy principle as
discovered primarily through the work of
Dalton Saktive Adebel in the last couple
of years. There's this nice duality
between the observer dependent the
viewpoint from the inside observer of
the agent and the outside observer. So,
respectively, the perspective of FEP as
opposed to constrained maximum entropy
principle. But Dalton has
demonstrated that actually, those two
perspectives can be unified through
showing the equivalency between the
Bayesian optimality and James
optimality. So from Bayesian optimality,
we can obtain FEP, and from Jane's
optimality, we can acquire
CMAP. So, given that the
notion of Bayesian lens also comprise
both Bayesian inference and
its inverse process, do you think the
Bayesian lens as providing a kind of,
I don't know, a tool to account for
showing this kind of duality between FEP
and constraint maximum entropy
principle? I think the answer is
probably yes. But I think this is a
really great question, because
genuinely, I don't know the story mean,
I know a bit about Dalton's work, and I
think it's wonderful, but I really don't
know yet how it connects to the stuff
I've been doing. And it's really like an
open question for me. But there are some
tantalizing signs that, as I say, I
think the answer to your question is
yes. There is a kind of unification of
the two kinds of story,
and some of the ingredients of that
story are kind of floating around out
there. So I know that there seems to
be a connection, or like I know that
there is a connection between quantities
like the relative entropy and energetic
concepts you get in physics. And through
that, you can make a link to the kinds
of things that Dalton has been doing
with gauge theory. And I feel like there
is a kind of geometrical structure that
you can put on top of these statistical
games that I've been working with,
because, remember, they are these lenses
with these loss functions. And these
loss functions seem to have this kind
of, as I say, this kind of geometric
thing going on with them. But really
explaining or putting constrained
maximum entropy into statistical games
language is not something that I've done
and it's something that I've been
thinking about doing, and I'd be
delighted to talk to people about more.
And so I don't know precisely the
details. There is a kind of other
duality, which I think is quite nice
which is related to this.
And I think again, at the nexus of these
is this systems theoretic idea,
because of course, all of this work of
Dalton's lives in this kind of dynamical
systems world where you have dynamical
systems that are interacting and
information flowing between them.
And there are some really tantalizing
connections, again, of course, between
physics and information processing. And
I learned the other day, for instance,
that there are certain classes of
generative adversarial networks sorry,
this is just a slight tangent, but I
think you might be interested to know
certain classes of generative
adversarial networks that you can set
them up. And the two parts
of the network tend to instead of
settling into an equilibrium, they seem
to exhibit some orbits around each other
so they don't achieve some equilibrium
state in the game they're playing. They
kind of just got around.
But somebody was telling me about if
you have an orbit and you're a
physicist, you think, okay, well, what
is that orbit conserving? Is there like
a quantity that it's conserving? And in
this case, and I don't know the details,
but in this case, this person found that
the quantity that was conserved in this
orbit was the relative entropy. And so
there's this weird thing going on.
These things are playing a game, but
they're still at this kind of somehow
steady state of relative entropy.
And so there seems to be this deep
connection between these kinds of game
like systems and sort
of information physics in some sense.
And I'm aware I need to head off for the
moment, but I just want to draw one more
picture. And I'm sorry, Elliot, you
probably had loads of questions, but we
kind of ran out of managed to answer
many of them, but hopefully we'll get to
the rest of them soon. But if I just
draw, as I say, one more picture,
which is a kind of slightly different
kind of duality, but a similar kind of
similar kind of flavor. So what we have
in systems theory is
this category. You have this category of
interfaces of systems and the morphisms
tell you how to wire these systems
together to give like hierarchical or
like composite systems.
And if
you have something like this thing which
I wrote before Din, which I said for
each interface I was like a category,
then you can sort of think of this as a
functor from int to
like cat the category of categories.
And one thing you can do with index
categories of this kind is you can sort
of turn them into what are called like
vibrations using what's known as the
Groton deconstruction. And if you know
about physics, you've probably heard of
a concept called a fiber bundle, which
is just like a collection of spaces
indexed by points of another space. And
so what you can do is you can write this
vibration which says, okay, well, for
each interface I've got a category of
systems on that interface and they're
all like glued together correspondingly
with the wirings of your interface
category. And so you write this as like
another function which kind of forgets
about the dynamical systems and just
returns the interface again. And so you
have this vibration thing here and this
is like where kind of like physics
lives.
And so what I've been trying to tell
this story about, in this story about
active inference is that you have a
similar one where you have for
each type of interface, the category of
agents that might have that interface.
Like we're all humans and so we are all
like the type that might fit in like a
human shaped box and so we're all in
that particular category and we come
together to form organizations and
that's another object of this category
of interfaces and another kind of agent
category on those interfaces. And so
that gives you another one of these
vibrations. And the thing that something
like predictive coding tells you is it
says, okay, well, given a certain story
about a type of agent,
can I turn that into a dynamical system
which actually animates it? And so
that's like a functor like this.
So maybe what we could do is we could
think of this as maybe like some version
of biology or we could think of this as
like we could think of this as like body
and we could sort of think of this as
like mind. And so this is telling us how
to go from a description of a mental
system to a sort of embodied system.
And I think some of what the free energy
principle is trying to say is that for
certain kinds of systems there's a way
to turn your description of a dynamical
system into something that looks like an
agent. And so the thing I'm wondering is
that whether there's some adjunction
or maybe this is like I don't know.
I don't know which way we might write
labels on these, but maybe there's,
like, some adjunction here that
allows us to compare these two processes
of turning a sort of mental
system into a physical one and then
going in the other direction from a
physical system into a mental one. And
so maybe this is also where information
comes in. And it's a kind
of similar story in category
theory where there's a sort of duality
between geometry and logic that
that's sort of sometimes written like
this. You have truth values down here
and you have logic over here
and you have space over here and
there's a way to sort of draw a picture
like this that says, okay, well,
logic is somehow like dual to space in
some sort of mumbo Jumboy way. I mean,
again, I've run out of time, but I think
there's a story that people try to tell
about science in this kind of abstract
world and I think it's a similar story
to maybe something that's being told
over here. Again, lots of details,
and I don't know precisely the
connection with Dalton's work, but I
think it's kind of pointing in this kind
of direction. Thank you,
topy. After you have revised
and proceeded,
let's have 54.3 and talk more about
action, active inference. So thank you.
Yeah, great. Thank you so much for
having me. And I look forward to
speaking again and answering your
questions. Ali, thank you so much. That
was great. Okay, great. Bye, guys.
Bye. Well,
I'd like to ask Dean a oh, Ali, please
make a remark. And then I have a yeah,
you know, I really think of Toby's work
as really provocative as
it really opens up Pandora's box of
many, many different fertile questions.
So I'm a firm believer
of this old saying that a sign of a
great book is not how many answers it
provides, but actually how many
questions it gives rise to. So I really
wanted to congratulate Toby on writing
such a I mean,
it looks as if he
began from the perspective of trying to
address some of the I don't know,
some long held questions, but then it
turned out to be much more deeper than
that in terms of actually giving rise to
many fertile questions. So, yeah,
that's really great.
Dean, I'd like to ask, what is the
difference or how can we think about
being on time in time and
out of time?
Because Toby said he was out of time
with the answer. And I know that we've
spoken about this when we consider some
of the time consciousness and category
theory work previously. So what is it to
be out of time? Yeah,
that's a great question. All I can say
at this point is that it's easier
to discretize when you're
in time and out of time as
a comparator than it is to say when
you're on time versus
those first two positions.
That's all I can say about that for now,
because I'm sure Toby,
from a diagrammatic perspective,
could probably tell us what is happening
when he's actually using his stylus
versus not right.
Like the result of that leaves something
in and out. But while he's actually
on point, he's literally
in a different place.
Here's an interesting thing, back to the
provocative Ali in the Dot. One was
talking about virtual and actual models
and was probably saying it in a way
that's completely different than how I
use. I believe those same
two models are in effect.
And so if
you, for example, draw up a
play, say, in sports, because we're
talking a lot of strategy while Toby was
on today and a lot of gaming theory and
stuff, you draw up a play, then you
confirm that you have all of the
elements or resources that you need in
order to be able to carry that out.
And then you're as a group communicating
with one another like we are doing on
this live stream, right? Like you're
literally calling out the play in North
American football. You'd huddle up and
literally call out a sequence of code
and then you'd have to literally reverse
that and turn the inference as
the shortest time window into
a prediction. Like you would literally
line up and then you would
carry out the simulation in actual
terms. All of that
together means that I believe that the
virtual version of the model is, as Toby
was saying, in the bi directional sense,
going in one direction, and the actual
model is going in 180 degrees
the opposite direction. And then when he
mentioned the dagger symbol today,
I was just like, okay, where does that
fit in to this bi directionality and the
difference between. The.
SIM, the digital, the virtual,
and the actual? So these are the things
that literally pop up at
any given moment, aren't necessarily
part of what you consider to be the
space that is inhabited by virtuality
and actuality. And yet there it is.
It just appears. And then you have to
sit down and figure out, well, where
does that categorically fit?
So again, don't want to go off on
a deep rabbit hole philosophical take
on this, but I just find that at any
given moment, there is again,
so much math in this philosophy that
it's kind of staggering. And just to be
able to have somebody who can explain
that and draw it out is
pretty impressive. I don't
know if it's provocative what I just
said. I hope it isn't because, man, I
did this work for almost a decade and
it seemed like young people weren't
scared by it. Maybe older folks are,
but I don't know.
So if I may add a brief comment on just
what you said, I was recently watching
this talk by John Bayes about the
history of applied category theory.
So he had this nice diagram
showing the relationship between
different areas of knowledge, I mean,
going from business to pure mathematics.
And he claimed that most
people in category theory, or in most
other areas, consider category theory
as being on the top
of the pyramid, as being the purest of
the pure, so as being even
kind of being on a meta level than
even the pure mathematics. But then he
said that I believe category theory can
actually be seen as kind of permeating
all of these levels. So it's not
something that sits on top of the
hierarchy. It's something that actually
can be seen as influencing and
permeating all the levels. So at
least from the perspective of applied
category theory, it seems to be,
if not self evident, but something that
gathers much, I mean, more evidence
as the research goes by. So I'm really
optimistic in the research direction
that applied category theory is going.
And hopefully in near future we can see
it applied to many, many different
areas, many different unforeseen areas.
I think I'll just tag on to that. Ali,
if you use an abductive logic
lens, then it's simply a question of
when did you enter, at what point did
you enter the abstracted
timeline? Because if you see it
that way, it's not just top down and
it's not just bottom up. It's back to my
question to Toby was,
does the whenness of this really
matter if you want to be able to
take it off the shelf and use it? And of
course, his answer was, yeah,
if you want to deal with idiosyncrasies,
you're left with no choice but actually
to acknowledge the point
in the continuum where you take this up.
But I think that actually makes it quite
easy to see it permeating every level.
But again, it's the abduction,
the abductive piece of this back to last
year in August, right? We're coming up
on one year since we talked about how
important that is, and yet here we are,
what, ten and a half months later,
and we're circling back. We have another
predictive parabolic on our. Heads.
Few comments on that. It's reminding
me of Professor Mike Levin's work on
basal cognition and the idea that
intelligence isn't on the top of the
pyramid either. Rather, it's something
that's distributed compositionally
across levels and something that exists
at all levels. And so we can then still
talk about higher order properties of
systems or properties of
composites or aggregate systems while
also grounding in
the foundations. Um.
Yeah, and that, and that grounding and
anchoring and stabilizing, that's by
itself is nothing
but a feature. I think you also want to
be able to, though, because there was a
lot of talk today about being able to
see this in the
way that things dynamically
play out. So, again, we're back to
the what's the minimum two ways that we
want to incorporate this observation,
both as stabilized and as searching.
Right. If we can have one eye on each at
all times, it does take a bit of
rethinking.
There is a there is a there is an
interoceptive piece to this. What we
feel from that is
different.
That brings us to the sensor fusion
aspects of the dissertation 7.1.1
Bayesian sensor fusion. Yeah.
A situation that is common in natural
embodied systems, but which is not yet
well treated by current statistical
machine learning methods. Also, Ali,
thanks so much for asking the Markov
blanket question. I think his response
is worthy, honestly, to review and
unpack in the time we have, we can just
sort of review a little bit and think
about what other questions we want to
prepare for. Two,
how would you, Ali, restate the
limitations of the Markov blanket
concept for all the positive things that
we've said in the previous 300 live
streams and where category theory can
help address and move past some of that?
Yeah, you see, this notion obviously
is one of the most or,
I don't know, probably one of the most
controversial concepts in whole FEP
literature because it has received a
fair amount of criticism from many
various perspectives. But some
criticisms, at least
as far as I know,
they're basically directed toward the
universality of Markov blanket. How
universal is this notion
as it's claimed to be ranging from, I
don't know, inert rocks to the brains,
right. So does it apply equally
for modeling inert rocks as well as
the most complex system we know of in
the whole universe, namely the brain?
So the response this line of
criticism got from the researchers in
the active inference area, again,
to the best of my understanding, is to
the effect that although theoretically,
it can be applied to many
different systems with many
different levels of complexity. But then
again, for simple linear systems
such as I don't know, many non
complex systems,
it doesn't have anything interesting to
say. So rather than being
applicable to all of these systems, the
relevant question should. Be.
There are enough insights we can gain
from applying this notion to many
different situations and systems.
So I believe Toby's
alternative for this problem by
proposing the polynomial function as
a replacement for Markup blanket can
cover this line of criticism pretty
nicely. It can address this criticism
pretty nicely due to its abstractness
and a kind of more rigorous way of
talking about both the universality and
the individuality of each system.
So I think that's a
nice way to at least a
viable answer to this
question that needs a lot more
consideration. So that's my take on
it as far as.
Okay, I'll give my
take two, which is the
Markov blanket concept, since the work
of Pearl in the 1990s is
actually not doing that much
philosophical work in and of itself. It
just describes the parents, the children
and the coparents of any given node
within a graph. So first, we're talking
about maps, not territories. We're not
talking about features of the world,
carving nature of the joints,
necessarily hashtag malandrus. We're
talking about the Bayesian graph. And
secondly, even on the graph, it's not
that a node is like by its essence an
internal state or a blanket state or an
action state if you use the Friston
blanket. Rather it's always in
relationship to others. So the concept
by itself does very little work.
However, people have deployed the
concept implicitly and explicitly to
describe interfaces of cybernetic
entities, the kinds of entities that it
makes sense to describe as an active
inference agent. So we know from the
particular physics and the strange kinds
work the path integrals paper that we
can describe using the
formalism, the rocks, the simple active
systems and the sophisticated active
systems. In. Order to have
an interface concept that does justice
to on one hand the relatively inert
interfaces, on the other hand,
potentially extremely conditional or
contextual interfaces.
Just having some
tagging system of nodes on
a Bayes graph is going to get extremely
messy. It's not that it couldn't be
done, but just in terms of actually
doing the programming, it's going to be
extremely messy. You're going to need to
have a lot of accessory or auxiliary
variables that indicate what the
current interface is at this time or
what it would be if this happened. And
all these kinds of conditionalities
would be like a less elegant way of
describing what our category theory
colleagues have been developing
explicitly with the wiring diagrams and
interfaces. So just to kind of conclude
there people draw the Bayesian graphs
and the particular physics is using
a Bayesian graph. However,
Bayesian graphs don't naturally have a
lot of these properties that
were really being conflated
with interfaces more generally. And by
using an interface concept, as Toby
said, at an intermediate level of
abstraction, that's slightly opinionated
but also really flexible, that is kind
of the right coarse graining, the right
optimal grasp on the interfaces that we
actually want to talk about for active
inference agents. And again, just trying
to get down to the firmware with the
Bayesian graph, we're going to get lost
in the details. And any accounting
system that we develop is going to be ad
hoc and certainly less principled or
powerful than what the category
theorists are developing. Yes.
Dean, I'm really curious what you
think of this. If we're talking about
the relationship with the interface,
could we see and I'm really asking this
question. I don't know, I'm spitballing
could we see the Markov blanket as the
more stabilized version or form of the
relationship and see the polynomial
version of that as the search version of
that relationship? What do you guys
think of that?
And I'm really asking, just listening to
both of you talk here, I'm just
wondering if I'm having one of those
unitary moments myself or if I'm way out
to.
Ali, give a first thought, then I'll
also give a speculative answer.
Yes. So one thing that comes to mind is,
you see, sometimes people consider
markup blanket as being a kind of static
boundary or interface that just
separates the agent from its
environment. But actually what it really
is is kind of providing really
a dynamic interface between those two
internal and external states. So it's
not a static or stabilized in any way.
But of course, in some situations we
treat it as if it's stable or,
I don't know, static coding.
Maxwell Ramstead every theory of markup
blanket is inherently per se, so there
isn't any static conception
of markup blanket at all.
But on the other hand, well,
obviously for the polynomial function,
not just polynomial function, but the
whole area, category theory deals
with objects not in their static sense,
but rather in the meaning
they acquire through their relations,
through their morphisms. And it's not
about so one of the main differences
between category theory and the set
theory is exactly hinges
on that distinction between the static
viewpoint of mathematical or, I don't
know even non mathematical objects and
the inherently dynamical or relational
identity of the objects as defined
in categories. So I believe polynomial
functions again, by themselves
are inherently
and intrinsically dynamical,
perceptual, and in the
terms of some continental philosophers,
such as Alan Badu,
they acquire existence through their
imminent relations.
They don't need any notion of
pre existence as some of the Platonic
notions of mathematical objects and
ideas. So yes, in this
sense, I think polynomial
functions, I'm not sure which one
can be seen as, I don't know, more
dynamic or processual than the other,
but at least to a degree,
both of those concepts can be seen as
sufficiently processual, in my view.
Awesome. Okay, I'll just add with a few
other associative comments. One is to
blanket something is to dampen and
stabilize it, whereas polynomial seems
to invoke, like many names, polynomos,
polytopos. So potentially there's a
multiplicity in the polynomial that
is not acknowledged. So lexically in the
Markov blanket and then a more formal
way to say that would be a Markov
blanket might be like a specific
realization of some little neighborhood
within the polynomial. So polynomial
functor is a generalization of the
Markov blanket. And so in that sense,
it requires more searching and it is
more abstract and it is more general.
But when you do stabilize it down,
then the Markov blanket formalism may
absolutely apply. But wherever
the Markov blanket formalism does apply,
like, let's just say that we stabilize
down to a computer system and we have an
API and we consider that that's one of
our blanket states. That would
also be seen as an interface, of course,
which is happy we'll talk about it. And
so it would be a polynomial function.
And so this helps us look back at
the literature and see,
as has been done many, many times in FEP
and other literatures, recent
developments enable previous
developments not to be invalidated, but
understood as special cases or
constrained or stabilized cases.
And it only makes sense that we would
start.
Well, putting aside what makes sense in
active inference, it seems that we are
taking both paths. In some cases leading
with the stabilized and generalizing,
but in other situations making unstable
generalizations that then precipitate
stability inside of them.
So more bi directionality.
Great. Well, we will have
a 54.3 with
a focus more on action. Are there any
other topics that you fellas
would like to raise? Or if anyone in the
chat wants to ask a question, please go
for it. In our last bit here,
let's look back to the table of contents
or Ali, please go for it. No,
just I wanted to ask Toby about the
relationship between his theory or
compositional account of statistical
inference as opposed to the
category theoretical account developed
about, I don't know, more than probably
ten years ago by people like Bob Kirky
and others specifically related to
the distinction between classical and
non classical Bayesian inference.
That's been clearly distinguished
in one of the papers from 2011.
I guess so, yeah. That's one question I
wanted to ask Toby, and of course a
subsequent question about the relation
of this distinction nondistinction
to the accounts of quantum FEP.
Because in quantum FEP markup blanket
is kind of replaced, or rather blended
with the notion of holographic
inner screen. So how
can we see quantum FEP as
arising from quantum Bayesianism
rather than from, I don't know,
predictive quantum theory and the
relation between those two frameworks of
Bayesian inference to that topic?
Awesome. Yes, the quantum
category theory active FEP triangle.
And also, I think the
question about reading the literature in
terms of the interfaces between a work
and the citations, I think is extremely
rich. It's a really novel
way to perform bibliographic
metaanalysis, but also just in our own
learning journeys.
This following this category theory
dictum of knowing a thing by its
relations understanding the paper
within the web of the past papers which
it cites, all of which are past and
actual and then its future time cone of
possible relationships to things that
haven't happened yet. The co parents
haven't even happened yet, necessarily.
But that becomes part of the evaluation
of the significance in the moment.
And if we could have the right
generative model and understand how much
attention to weight onto different
things in the moment, that would be like
being able to see the whole time cone at
the right core screening. But of course,
as limited nest mates we can't do that.
But we have our rules, our heuristics
and our approaches that address that
nonetheless.
Anyone in the Chat or Dean, what would
you like to explore in 54.3?
I'm just going to follow the two of you.
I got two big workhorses here.
I just got to get out of the way so I
don't get trampled.
Let's look at the table of contents
here. We're just shifting to the code of
document, the back end that we use to
coordinate a lot of our work just
so that it can all be seen in the video.
Chapter one is short.
Chapter two, if someone is looking for
another account of like, why does
category theory matter?
Toby begins chapter two with three
examples of situations neural circuits,
Bayesian networks and computations where
people often just use a kind of
schematic diagram but it's not necessary
or sufficient to really convey all of
the richness that we can add on with
category theory.
Chapter three starts getting into more
detail with string diagrams and
developing towards circuit diagrams in
this rate coding neural setting,
a lot more new vocabulary arising along
the way. Chapter four,
which the question the beginning of this
Livestream brought a focus to, is on
the compositional aspects of
probability. The copy discard
structure is introduced, which we saw in
the diagram today. That's when the piece
of information is duplicated and then
one of them can be thrown away Bayesian
inversion, the dagger, Lady Macbeth's
dagger always just dangling
there. Then the growth
and deek construction,
bringing back strong recall
of Shauna Dobson, Chris Field's, math,
art and the complexity of the self.
Chapter five went into dynamical
systems. Markov chains
open and closed dynamical systems
with this polynomial interface concept.
It's really built up in an extremely
methodical way. First the dynamical
system is kept, within a nutshell,
extremely bounded, but then it's
progressively opened up. And so even
though it's going to be a lot of new
information reading the dissertation,
it's done in a way that does also
clearly build upon itself. Chapter six
goes into the Bayesian lenses, connects
to several more prevalent concepts
in statistics maximum likelihood
estimation, approximate Bayesian
inference, auto encoders, and connects
this to the emerging concepts of
Bayesian lenses and statistical games in
terms of the approximate inference
doctrines in chapter seven. Yeah, Ali,
please. No, I just wanted to mention
this particular chapter is being
rewritten at the moment, so yeah,
that's thank you. Absolutely. Yes.
As we discussed a little earlier,
chapter six is going to get simpler but
better, but it was tricky. But it's
simpler. But it's better. But it was
tricky.
And then chapter seven closes it out,
but really opens it up with the
compositional, cognitive cartography
sailing the Three Seas society of
systems more alliteration,
many, many connections to areas
of interest for all system scientists
and complexity enthusiasts.
What a tour de force and a
journey. And it's going to be awesome
that we'll get to see some of the
next increments in the work. Talk more
with Toby. Yes, Dean?
Can I just throw this in? And it's going
to indicate how old I am. But a
long time ago, the first time a needle
dropped on the first Van Halen album,
something changed about everything that
we thought about guitar playing. And if
you weren't there in that moment, you
wouldn't know how everything changed.
I'm not sure what category theory taken
up on a mass scale will do if it will be
the equivalent moment for all people
who use math in all the
different ways that they use it, but I
think that we are at the beginning of
something that it is going to change
things. And I don't know exactly how
it's going to change things, but I
think this will always now be included
as how we try to both
figure things out and out the figures in
that three dimensional space. I mean,
one of the things that I thought was
interesting in the dot one was when Toby
said, well, I work in 2D space and
now I'm curious about I wonder what that
would look like. Well, we exist
in a 3D space and so I think the
applicability of it is going off at any
given moment. But I do really think this
is the start of something.
I'm not sure exactly what, but I
don't think we'll be able to unlearn
this. I think it's going to remain
influential for a long time.
For those about to categorify, we salute
you. Yeah. Right. There we
go. Thank you.
You can always make it better.
Any other thoughts on this? Otherwise.
Great. Yeah. Ali, please with any last
thoughts? No, I just wanted to say
I'm really looking forward for the next
installment. I hope it happens soon
because again, I have so many
burning questions. I try mean
whittle it down to some I don't know,
not too much time consuming questions.
But yeah, I'm really interested in I'm
curious to know Toby's answers to them.
So thank you so much for everything,
for organizing this and inviting Toby.
Oh, absolutely. All right,
thank you, everybody. See you in 54.3.
Bye.